so how many people have already like
played a bit with PI spark I guess not
many yeah ten percent less ok so I'm we
were actually not planning to give like
a really basic overview of spark but
we're going to spend like two minutes
just given some you know like
definitions of the spot you know spark
concepts and then the idea is that we
had two parts prepared with the first
part we're going to cover spark or so
this is the core functionality of spark
and we will we've got some questions on
exercises if we have time and talk a bit
about the spark execution model it's
very important if you know later on your
building you know full-fledged
applications and it doesn't work or it
doesn't or fails or it's not very
performant and you need to understand a
bit how it works behind the scenes and
the second part is so it's my colleagues
ahan is going to do it it's about data
frames and spark askew L which is a you
know new thing that came with I think
from version 1.3 and 1.4 as well so it's
new it's just a new feature ok so these
are just some you know very briefly some
definitions of spark if I had to give a
crash course in two minutes of spark
this is what I would say so a spark uses
something called an RDD which is every
stands for resilient distributed data
set which is a distributed data set okay
and so let's imagine gavel in a huge
data set and you have to divide it in
two partitions okay so that's a word
that I'm going to be using a lot of
partitions and so spark gives you the
possibility to cache data in memory so
that's quite nice and then in terms of
data manipulation so usually you would
use park in a cluster right where you
have a master node and some slave nodes
and we can apply transformations to the
data through the spark context because
it's another important concept spar
context and only the master node has
access to that spark context so you can
only you know
tell spark to transform your data
through the spark context which is and
you know you can control through the
master node from the master node I hope
that's sort of clear but ok so these are
the data sets that we are going to be
working with their sample data set from
amazon there there are four of them so
three of them there are JSON files
fashion electronics and sports there are
product reviews and you're the one
sample made a data or JSON there its
metadata about products so you will have
to price the category of the product and
other information about the product okay
and also like credits this is come from
two papers and okay yeah so which link
are you trying yeah sorry that one
doesn't work you should try the one
that's on the instructions sorry about
that so last minute change ok so now I'm
going to go to my ipython notebook but
again you can everything I'm going to be
running here if you've got the shell you
can just start running as well right so
you can just copy and paste what I'm so
the what you have to do is once you
download if you want to run this exactly
as I'm going to be running it if you
downloaded folder you have to go into
the folder after you unzip it and then
you launch spice Park once you're inside
a folder yeah cause otherwise the paths
now these paths are all relative to you
being inside a folder that was it won't
work all right so you know first steps
creating on our DD so as I said energy
DS a distributed data set so what we can
do is in the shell you already have this
viable as C which is a spark context so
if you want to attach some like a text
file or some data to your spark context
you use as C dot txt file okay so in
this case we are creating three
different rd
is one for each text file that we have
so one for the fashion reviews another
one for the electronics reviews another
one for the support reviews ok I'm going
to be running this now all right ok done
so as you saw so just one note as you
saw just run this reliance and it took
like you know very short time and it's
because no data was actually moved or
red or anything this is this is part of
the lazy evaluation of spark right it
just it's very lazy doesn't actually do
anything until you trigger an action in
this case this is not an action this is
just like a definition of you know
fashion is an RDD and the data is in
this file ok all right now we've got the
the next thing we can do is count the
number of rows in the RDD ok so what you
can do is you take fashion or
electronics and you just use this
function count and it will tell you how
many lines they are in each rdd need
file and finally you can you can also
use that first to just get the first
element of your eye dee dee ok so as you
can see fashion has 10,000 rows so does
electronics and sports and then the
first row so it's a string and you've
got all these fields so you've got the a
scene which is a product identifier for
that the amazon product identifier for
that specific product and here you've
got the review text so some you know
somebody bought a 22 and the overall
which is a score and you know other
fields that could be interesting then
another thing we can do it's to Union
like multiple r dds ok so in this case I
want just a single r DD that has
contains the data in those three files
so one option is to take the union of
those three rd DS ok and
and that's what I'm doing and as you can
see again the first line is the same
thing as before but now this union of
our dd's contains the data in the three
files so in the fashion electronics on
the sports one so okay so this is basic
you know loading a file creating a union
abilities counting the number of rows
taking the first element now let's
imagine that so we've got this our DD
and the first row looks like this it's a
string but but real it's a dictionary
and we would like to have it in you know
as a Python dictionary we don't want it
as a string so that if it's a Python
dictionary then you can just call you
know the different fields directly you
can say give me the a scene right so for
that we are going to use the JSON
library in Python and then we can just
apply a mapper so a map basically we'll
take the data and will apply the same
function on all the rows of your data
set so in this case we're telling it
take your take fashion which is an RDD
and on each row you apply this function
J standard loads and by doing this we're
turning so what previously was a string
now it's the dictionary okay so this is
if you use Python I means like the map
function in Python summer okay another
thing you can do so instead of having to
create one rdd per file that we want to
work with you know that's if you have
10,000 files that's a little bit tedious
so what you can do is just passing you
know a list of comma-separated file
paths or or use like patterns right
wildcards so in this case we're just
going to give you know this list of
comma-separated files to the to the
spark context and if we do that then we
just have one our DD with all the data
okay now this is a question so if i do
that
how many partitions do you think I will
have in my rdd yes this does anybody
know why it's three so when you when you
load a text file right spike doesn't
know I mean doesn't know anything
doesn't know how to partition your data
so Apriori will just take as you know
one partition profile right so that's it
so you've got three partitions in this
dataset and this function get non
partitions i I've personally find it
really useful because when things break
or you know the number of partitions is
always something that as we will see
later you need to tune so it's always
important to understand exactly you know
how many partitions you have throughout
all your operations you know if you need
to debug your your code at some point so
just remember captain partitions very
useful Oh something I forgot to say
actually is that a very very useful
thing of spark is that you can go into
the application dashboard so in this
case it's a because i'm running pi spark
locally right it's just on my localhost
but otherwise you would put in here
let's imagine that you use ec2 instances
on amazon you would just put the IP
address of your master node here and
then you can you can go into this
dashboard and this tells you exactly for
example how many executors you have in
this case because it's local it only
shows one but normally I would have
liked as many executives as I have nodes
in my cluster it tells you like all the
properties of your cluster and whether
you've cast anything so the storage here
tells you you know whether it does
anything sitting in memory and and here
okay we don't see anything at the moment
but normally if you run something then
they will start showing you what you're
being running okay yes
yeah i mean sure okay so sahan will
cover a bit of this so with data frames
you can i trace you know define a schema
and you can tell it's a JSON file and it
has these columns but yeah so maybe wait
a little bit until later yes so you have
the proper sorry I just not here it's a
pity you don't have like your microphone
or something oh there's a microphone
another puppy amazing okay thank you so
much
and so what I think you were on the 900
26 port right to vote for the monitoring
to do what to when you were monitoring
the spark job just before that this one
yeah sorry you are nah oh yes you is
this okay yes that one when I run that
in a ec2 instance most of the time I
can't navigate the don't manage to login
tag to see this hey I only see sparks
stages basically and if I run something
i have a link but I I can't do anything
with that link is something you
encountered before okay no sorry you're
not really sure what what's the problem
sorry about that I mean sometimes you
know if you have a cluster of ec2
instances it might be that the I mean
you have to look at your inbound
properties of an outbound so sometimes
maybe you need to go into the AWS
account and check some of the
configurations of your cluster okay
maybe later you can show me like okay so
we're here right so one this is another
function okay my partitions with index
which i think is very useful now before
we had a map right and map applies one
function per row in your data set now my
partitions applies the function on the
entire partition so it's it's slightly
different and and here i put a link so
you know the documentation is is here so
if you ever have any questions about you
know whether you know what was the
functionality of spark or you know what
kind of functions can i apply there are
some examples as well so in this case
you can also find my partitions right
and it tells you you know it gives you a
couple of examples of how it works so so
in this case what i want to do is count
the number of lines
partition okay not the total number of
rows i have but how many rows you are
having partition one in partition to and
in partition three right so my
partitions with index gives you two
variables one of them is the partition
index and you're the one is an iterator
over your data in that sitting in that
partition so then here all I'm doing is
just taking the length over you know the
whatever is in the partition and collect
is another nice function that you should
be aware of as well if you use Park
which is basically when you take all
your data that's said sitting in your in
your slave nodes for that specific rdd
and just collect it in the master node
and then it's just like a Python you
know normal Python object and you can do
whatever you want with it so in this
case what I see here is that I've got
you know as expected three partitions 01
/ file and the number of lines per
partition is 10,000 you know again it's
as expected because we had three files
where each of them had 10,000 rows so
nothing weird happening okay next thing
reducers all right so how many of you
are just familiar with in like MapReduce
paradigm in general okay that's good
quite a few so something that is very
like or to the spark is this idea like
you know reduce reduce Becky just part
of the MapReduce paradigm so let's
imagine that we want to know the number
of reviews for products okay so we have
an idea like how popular each product is
so something we can do is take our data
so our data has all the product reviews
we take the a scene of that product and
we counted as one so we say you know
this predator has been reviewed once and
then we do I reduce by key where we just
add the values of two tuples so the way
it works I'm here I've done a little
diagram okay so let's imagine so one
product is a sin one
okay and we have five reviews for a
scene 1 so what the ribbed use my key
does is that it will take two couples at
first right with where the first element
is the icing and sickle amount is a one
and it sums them it sums the values
right so in this case you have a scene 2
then it takes another one and again it
will do it will do that again so we will
take the two values again and I will
send them so then you have a scene 3 and
it does that over the data until you get
you know the final answer which is you
have five reviews for a scene 1 so this
is a sketch of how reduced by key works
so in order to apply reduce by key or in
general like any any function as by key
in it I grew by key or by key then you
always have to have key value pairs so
your data has to be in the format a key
that has to be hashable and a value
which could be whatever you could be a
list could be text could be whatever you
want so in this case the the key is the
icing is a string and the value is 1 and
then here XY is the two like the values
of two different tuples all right so
like to once or like a 1 and a 2 here
for you know to get 3 so you get the
idea okay so once we do that if we want
to know what's the maximum and minimum
number of reviews in a product and you
know it's very simple we just grab the
second field of product num okay so
product num contains the a scene and the
total number of reviews and then we just
take a maximum over that and for minimum
just take the minimum and that's it so r
and s and it tells you that the maximum
number of reviews is 2033 and the
minimum number is one okay so i had an
exercise here but i mean i think we're
probably running out of time a little
bit so i'm just going to leave that but
you know you can do this on your own
time and you know the question is what
is the maximum score now for each
product so how can you create an RDD
that gives that has
the a scenes and the maximum score for
that specific a scene again it's
basically you know like a little spoiler
it's the same thing as this only instead
of adding the scores you take the
maximum over two scores okay all right
next Joan in multiple sources so we've
only been working with the product
reviews but we also have this meta data
that we could use so okay so we're just
going to start by loading the metadata
that we have okay and as you can see the
metadata also has the icing and has
information about the products like the
title of the product the image URL we
have the categories so the categories
are encoded as a list of lists so we're
going to change that right round like
next next thing we're going to do okay
so you've got lots of useful information
now okay this is just because we don't
like this list of lists things so we're
just going to flatten the categories so
that it only shows one list okay so this
is what flattened categories does you
don't need to look into the co2 much
just just you know to take it as a given
it takes a list of lists and outputs a
list with a flat structure so we're just
going to apply that okay no next we yes
so we want to join the reviews with a
product metadata right so we want to
know you know person review this product
and we want to I don't know for example
know that category of that product that
the person reviewed right so what we
need to do is we cannot just apply a
join and again as with many operations
and spark you need to have key value
pairs right so we're going to start by
taking the reviews and we transform it
into key value pair with your keys the
icing and the the value is just you know
the whole review the whole review field
and for the metadata will do the exactly
the same thing we take the AC nozaki and
the rest of the metadata in here so okay
and once we have key value pairs for the
data and metadata and we can just apply
join on it okay all right so as you can
see this is the output of the join this
is the key that was used to join so it's
the ace in this is the product review
for that you know a specific product
review for that a scene and this is as
the metadata that we have about that a
sin right so um what is this yeah
basically it's just some gadget
blackberry got it good I think I might
skip this okay this is basically what i
was trying to show here is that you know
if you want to know the number of
partitions of a joint RDD it's actually
not an obvious thing to know like unless
you know exactly how the joint is
performed so something that sahana and
me have to do all the time if we want to
know exactly how it's done right inside
is that we just go to the you know pi
spark code you know going to the code
the Python code is always a good idea if
you're trying to figure how think things
are done right so yeah it's just a
little side comment so in this case the
number of partitions for a joint is the
number of the sum over the number of
partitions of your 2 r.d DS that you're
joining okay but it's it's not a trivial
or straightforward thing it's just you
need to go to the code to check how it's
done alright so now we've done this okay
you saw that the structure is actually
not very nice looking right i mean it's
like a at opal where the second element
is a list of dictionaries so it's not
very nice I just want a single
dictionary I want to make it nice right
so what I do here is that I just say
okay merge to two dictionaries from the
metadata under reviews and I do that so
I do that and then I just get a single
a single Python dictionary where I have
everything for all the information here
about a specific review but i also know
something about you know the product
like I know which category it is and the
title right and lots of things like this
okay so this is just a couple of
questions to you know probe your
understanding of spark so this function
here change title takes the title field
right of a dictionary and changes the
title right so I'm going to apply this
to my the previous structure that I show
you okay i'm going to call it categories
new rtd and the question here is that
what is if i print this right which is
basically taking the title of the first
element of categories what do you think
you will print okay so you know
previously this was a title like privacy
screen saver blah blah blah and now i
apply this function oh it's just gonna
print like this is a title right it mean
so far so good okay as expected now this
is when it gets less stress for stress
forward what will it print if I take now
a nice joint which was my original
already d and I applied no sorry and I
don't apply anything I just want to
print the first title right so in this
case it could either print this is the
title or you could print the original
one right and it's the original one so
I'm trying to show here is that okay
we've we've applied some operations on
nice joint but these operations are
attached to a new itd okay does we
haven't changed your regional RDD we
just created a new rdd it's just like
you know new Python variable that
contains like you know this these
transformations on this data but the
original one has not changed it's still
the same and this I'm going to give it
for you you know in your own time if you
want to check this it's a little bit
it's more tricky but
I think it's worth not i'm not going to
it basically yeah all right um next
thing goodbye key so actually have some
slides think where you're kind of okay
with time so I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
slides so alright so something that I
had I mean I've like learned now after
using spy for a year is that
understanding the spark internals is
definitely worth it because a lot of
times your job doesn't perform as you
expect or it fails or it hangs and you
know if you don't understand exactly
what it's trying to do and you know how
your data looks like at that time or how
many partitions you have then then it's
just very difficult to debug it okay so
I really recommend this talk here put
the link there it's by one of them you
know founders of spark and its really
it's a very good talk and he gives a lot
of really nice examples and I just tried
to copy like some of the things that he
was saying but very condensed version
here so how does the spark execution
engine work again so let's imagine we
have this code right what we're doing is
what we are what we've been doing before
we're loading product reviews we
applying a map function where we extract
the a scene and the score then we grew
by key right where we group all the
product essence so we group all the
scores for a specific product icing and
then we just filter we only interested
in the ones that have a list that have
been scored at least twice and then we
count the number of products I have a
list two scores okay so this is how are
they that looks like this is the eighth
in this is a score okay so at first so
this is the output of the mapper right
because we only we only get these two
fields then we apply goodbye key so we
group all the rows by product asing so
in this case we have just one score for
this product icing and two scores for
this product
Sen right so when you grew by key you
end up with as a value you end up with a
list of scores right and finally we
filter the ones that have at least two
scores so this one is not interesting so
we just will throw it away and then we
count the number of products that you
know pass all this constraints ok so
just simple example and so what does
party okay so you have the code the
first thing is that the this is more
conceptually but it it creates a sort of
a graph of Rd DS where you know it's
just a sequence of operations that you
apply on your DD have the first one is
the map then the goodbye key and then
the filter right so this is very simple
I mean you probably also do this when
you're designing code or in your head
like you know you know desired is the
steps that this is part the each step of
the pipeline right but then this is
where the tricky part comes speak spark
figures out what is the best way to
execute this operations so in order not
to have to iterate over the data
multiple times unnecessarily it will try
to for example take two different map
functions and then just fuse them into
one single operation okay so you will
try to fuse operations as much as
possible and but you can only few so
much right for example if you have a
stage where or you have an operation
that where your data has to be
reshuffled right or your data has to be
reorganized or you know in this case in
the group by key the output of the group
by key depends on the output of the
previous mapper to be to be finished
because this partition here will depend
on two different partitions in the map
level so whereas before like for example
in the filter it's a linear operation
right so you only if you filter one
partition and it's completely
independent of what the other data looks
like bring the case of the ghoul bikie
no it's not independently did you depend
on the previous computation to be to be
finished so this is when spark creates
this idea of stages so it takes
computations put them together and it
says okay this is one stage and you can
only start the next stage
when the first one is finished right so
that's what I wanted to say and then
again then once it has done this you
know optimization then it schedules the
tasks and execute them okay and this is
a shuffle okay so I shuffle is basically
an operation that as I said earlier that
involves reshuffling of the data it
involves the data having to go to places
right so there is some network overhead
here because you need to send it you
know the data from one physical place to
another physical place and and in this
case for the group the group by key is a
shuffle because you want to group your
data by the eighth sense right but the
for example this product right might be
in the like distributor and all the
partitions but you want to group it into
a single partition so what you will need
to do is take all this the instances of
this a sin and send it to the same
pocket so send it to the same place the
same output place which is what it's
doing here so we take this this
specification sitting here here and here
and we have to send it here to the same
place so as you can see this operation
is not it's not linear at all and it's
okay so it's what we call a shuffle and
in our experience they're usually
they've tended to be the bottleneck for
most things that we're trying to do
because you can imagine that if you have
a very large task or a very large
partition then it will you will run out
of memory at some point so if one of
those you know blue things which has to
sit in memory it's huge then you know
you might run in in problems into out of
memory problems the other thing is if
you have too many tasks then this is too
much network overhead because you need
to send too many files right so this is
another thing to bear in mind if you
have too few tasks then you might not be
utilizing the cluster optimally so maybe
some nodes are not doing any work so
something to bear in mind so in the talk
that from the spark founder this is this
is some of the guidelines that he got
the conventions so usually one between
110,000 partitions you want it to be at
least twice the number of course to make
sure that your your cluster is fully
utilized and you want a task to take at
least 100 milliseconds because if it
takes less then you probably you know
that trade-off between network overhead
and how big your particular partition is
right so if you text less than 100
milliseconds you play having to send too
many files around are too small so it's
you know you can pray increase the size
of the partition okay so the last bit of
my part my part of my talk this is a
group Becky so yeah I'm gonna go just
very very quickly arrayed in here what
we're trying to do is we want to count
the number of reviews per category okay
so just as a reminder this is what nice
joint looked like first so nice joint
was a you know big dictionary with the
review in the metadata information and
we want to just count the number of
reviews per category and the categories
are a list so I encoded as a list so
what we need to do first is a flat map
okay we need to flatten this out so that
we count for this specific review we
count you know category electronics has
been reviewed to one's computer and
accessories has been rebuked once and so
on right now so this is what we do here
we do a flat map with the categories
okay so we're going to do this so as you
can see we have 925 categories and this
is the output of the flat map so we're
only taking five elements and you know
it's not a list of lists anymore it's
just sorry yeah yeah I physic is not a
list of Lists yeah it's just flatten out
to be only single categories
now we'll win it what we want to do want
to count the number of reviews per
category so we do the same thing we did
before so after the flat map we're gonna
do a reduced by key where we are going
to count the number of categories the
number of reviews forget the great okay
and again you know you can collect so
this our DD category total count has the
category and the total number of reviews
in the in the top hole so you can
collect it and then you can perform any
operation you would do normally like in
normal Python so in this case i want to
sort them and I want to check what are
the top five categories with the most
number of reviews okay and okay and yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I mean is how much
your Python like your driver can take so
if you can take like no one gig around
1k two gigs maybe to fix it so much in
my experience at one gag
so what I do usually well I mean a
simple thing is just check one row see
how many rows you have i multiply by the
you know the site they expected size or
isn't for the row but other thing
another thing that I do is I cash it so
you can take you can do nice joint-top
cash so let me see if I can do it now
actually so nice joint cash and then I
count joint account so yeah I counted I
need to count because that's it it's an
action so if unless you have a knife you
know an action I counter collect then
because of the lazy evaluation it won't
do anything so you always have to count
and in this case I really know it's not
showing me anything here all right I
don't know normally the webui you should
see here the RDD and you should tell you
how many partitions you have and the
size of memory that's why do I don't
know why it's not showing here maybe
something with a fact that it's local I
don't know but that's another way that I
I check the size of my already okay so
yeah going back to what I was trying to
do here this is just to show how to use
group likey so in this case I want to
group all so I want to get the average
product review length for its category
so what I do is I want to group all the
lengths of the product reviews for each
category and then get the average right
so what I do is here it's a flat map
where I take the category as a key and
this is the length of the product review
and then so let me show you an example
ok so after the group Becky for example
this is this is telling me that screen
protectors has ten different reviews and
these are the lengths of each review
okay so this is after the group I key
and then what I do is I take the average
all right by taking the sum over all the
lengths and divide by the number of
product reviews in this case like the
average of screen protector is 423
characters and again you can collect and
just check it out on normal Python okay
so this is it for me again I had here a
little exercise that you can do in your
own time and then a couple of notes
about data skewness so this is a very
typical problem that you will see when
you deal with real data so again you can
check this out in your own in your own
time and i also had this is how to you
know how to broadcast a variable and in
this case we're broadcasting a cycle
learn object to apply it on the text
data and predict something out of the
text a tepid we don't have too much time
on it but you can run this later on so
now my colleagues our hands want to talk
about data frames there you go
so you guys want to have like a two
minute break like a really quick one or
should we just go straight ahead ok cool
yep so yep good morning everyone I'm
saan i work as a data science engineer
at skin llings so yeah earlier so in the
part 1 maria was talking about you know
this power co and in my part it's all
right yeah so in my part I'm going to
focus on two things that's the first the
first thing is the data frames API and
spark seeker so we start again ok so
what's the data frame a data frame the
definition of data frame is it's a
collection of data with named columns so
the collection of data part is as same
as the rdd concept but then in addition
to that a data frame has column names
and what is sick well I mean spark
secure it's the same I mean it's a
sequel like language which can be used
to query from big data using you know
from our dd's like data frames so before
we start how many of you guys have
worked with the end of state frames good
and how many of you are familiar with
our ok I've got good news for you so
data frame API is very similar to pandas
are data frames and let's get the second
part who's who hasn't worked with psycho
that's a bad question
whose work bit sick oh okay so who's
worked with pipe okay good so sparks
equal in any sense it's pretty much you
know it has this catalyst sequel engine
which takes in sequel like queries and
optimizes them and you know scales it up
to work with petabytes of data and then
in sparks equal itself there is this
component called the hype context which
can be used to be more creative add more
hive ql h TL functionality with your
data frames so before we go to the
tutorial again let's just quickly catch
up i meanyeah this rd DS there's data
frames what's the big difference so if i
want to summarize this slide in one
point data frames have schema and our
dd's don't so if we drill down into it
so data data in our d DS they are they
stored as independent opaque objects
whereas in data frames we have column
names for different you know even in the
data object thus just metadata component
which has the column names and the data
types for these data and our d DS they
due process optimization so Maria was
digging deep into it and so what it
means is we give we give the coast park
API something to do it builds a direct
directed acyclic graph out of it and
then it launches a pipeline data
pipeline whereas data frames because
they have additional information on top
of that it uses the schematic
information to do for the optimizations
for example spark knows that the age
column is integer so it knows which data
to expect and which compression
algorithms work best with integers so it
uses this sort of information to further
optimize the data pipeline and in terms
of usability
when you look at our dd's you tell spark
what to do how to obtain the data you
need and you try to conceal
conceptualize everything in terms of key
value pairs tuples and you refer to all
these tuples indices whereas in data
frames you tell it what you need you
tell it okay I need this data frame and
I need these columns with this following
criteria and the optimizer figures out
the rest so one thing before we leave
this slide are dd's can be transformed
to data frames and vice versa so without
further ado let's go to the tutorial
ok
so yeah so let's just skim through the
first bit because so the first code
snippet it's just vanilla spark API I
mean co API using text file to load this
data and so if you can see yeah I mean
Maria explain to you every line is a
JSON object represented in a string but
if you look at this Jason for instance
you have column names and when you look
at it you can have an idea about you
know what the data types are you can see
that the review ID is a string you can
see that the UNIX review time is a long
or an integer so when you have this sort
of information embedded in your data
structures you can directly load it into
a data frame so there are two ways that
you can use to you know load data into a
data frame one way the first way is the
easy way where you just dump the file
path into the data frame API and it
figures out what data it contains what
are the column names what are the data
types and the second way to do it is the
developer can manually define the schema
and say okay here's the data set this is
the scheme of the data set comply with
it so to do all these things first you
need the sequel context so when you work
with the cove rd DS you work with spark
context when you work with data frames
you need this equal context if you want
to get more creative there's hype
context but for this tutorial I will use
the sequel context so first we check if
the secure country is working yes it's
working so in this code snippet what I
am doing is I am loading this JSON file
using the JSON file function in the
sexual context with the file paths so
here I am not defining anything about
the schema so sparks go spark goes ahead
and it will figure out the schema so now
you can see in contrast to the earlier
result now we have a row object with
different column names
and you know we have strings we have
tuples we have decimals we have all
these different data fun and one handy
function that you get in these data
frames is there's a function called
print schema which you can just use to
observe what sort of a schema you end up
with so if you look at this you have the
row of checked inside that you have
these different columns and for each
column name you have a data type and you
have a nullable boolean flag so you can
actually so the second way is the
manually like manually specifying the
schema so if you to do that first we
have to you know specify the schema for
that they're so spark spark provides you
these type classes that can be found in
unifies by sparks equal module that can
be used to define these schema data
types so what you can see here ESA's
like is the data is the schema that I
defined for the earlier data set so i
have this review ID is in reviva name
help like helpful all these column names
and I have these variable types at the
data type and this flag here is is the
novel flag so you can say if this
variable can be now or not so here in
this particular face I am not actually
assigning the schema to the data i am
just building it so something you can
observe here is that some of the fields
are missing so if you look at this
summary field here which is missing in
the in the schema and then there's the
unix review of time so while let's just
start off with this so i will give you
three minutes of which every one minute
i will give you guys a clue let's try to
you know build the schema so first i
will give you one club every field is a
struct field which has a column name
which should be the column name in the
JSON file which has to have a data type
and which has to have the knowledge back
for now let's assume it's true is
anybody typing no
okay so yep I'll give you the first hint
to make it more interesting so this is
what the column would look like like a
column name I mean each column will have
a strong field similar to this and the
data types would have to change
depending on so you can refer to the
schema that's spark inferred to get some
help from there okay let's do this now
so first let's let's implement the
summary field which is summary and
summary according to this is a string so
we have implemented string type before
so string types comes here and it's yeah
let's say it can be now and the next one
is unix review time so put that here and
that is loan so we haven't implemented
long here so let's simply meant long
time work
so if you want to get more like here
there are a couple of data types that I
have implemented but if you want to get
the full you know overview of all the
data data types and their requirements
parameter so on and so forth you can go
to this link in the notebook and it will
give you all the details about different
data types so now we built this truck
built this schema structure now we have
to apply that to the data set we have so
I am using the same function JSON file
function that is used to read JSON files
into a data frame so i am i am using the
same file paths which is a string of you
know the file paths but additionally i
am passing the scheme I inside as a
parameter so when i do that i get the
raw object and yeah with the schema that
i applied to it and so from there now
we've loaded the data set now let's
discuss about you know save like the
date what can data frames do so data
frames most of the day like most of the
functions that you can find in our DD
they have a counterpart in data frames
so for example map has for each function
select function in data frames Mac
partition has its for each partition
counterpart filter there's a filter in
data frames as well for the flavors of
you know group by key reduced by key you
have a group by function which is very
similar to sequel and yeah join you have
a joint so let's just you know dive into
some of the operations that you can do
with data frames and just you know get
on with it so first we will do what we
will do is we will filter certain
columns from a data set so if you are
using sake will you use select to do
this if you are using our dd's you use
Mac to do this so what we do here is we
use the Select statement
and so we built this applied data frame
from by applying this schema in the
earlier stage so we are doing a select
on this applied data frame and I am
selecting the ace in overall review text
unix review time and yes so once you run
this you get the you get the picture so
you have the columns that you need and
something i also want to point out this
column DF like dot show function it's
very similar to first 0 dot take
function in our dd's basic hard it is it
just lets you you know visualize the
result and you know see the data so here
i would like to do a small exercise so
map in our dd's they can be used to
select columns at the same time you can
use it to do an operation on a column
let's say you know at +1 to a school or
divide it by a constant or something
like that so do you guys think if the
Select statement could do that who would
say yes who would say no okay
well the answer is yes so you can use so
i have another exercise here so what i
am trying to do here is so there's a
helpful there's a far there's a does
feel call helpful in the data frame i
want to use that and what i want to do
is so the helpful field is the numerator
and the denominator of you know how
helpful it was from like out of like out
of peer this many people how many people
called it as helpful so what we actually
need like in terms of you know data
science or whatever is that actual
fraction so let's now implement how we
do that operation I'm kind of skipping
the exercises because of the time
constraints well but you'll get the idea
so you have applied DF and the help full
column which has which which is a topple
which has to interior too long integers
in it so you have the numerator and you
divide that by the denominator and yes
so now what I did here is yeah so you
can do polymerize operations on select
and now the other problem we have is
this guy so it's when you want to do the
next select in the next stage you don't
want to deal with this column name do
you so would anybody have an idea how we
could rename this column as
let's try ass helpful now let's try this
as a straight no so yes so the point is
as doesn't the keyword ass doesn't work
with the the Select statement so in a
data frame how you do it is you get this
product and now you have this you know
produced data frame object and you run
the next step on this object and there's
a function call with renamed column let
me check that out yes with column
renamed renamed and the arguments you
give this function is the first one is
the existing column which is this whole
thing because by the time we get to this
dot this step of this transformation has
already happened so at that point what
you have is this column itself so what
you do is you take that you put it here
and you rename it to helpful so yes so
we did we did this division and now we
can see loads of null values here does
anybody have an idea why this could be
yeah good so we have this device
division by zero and so null values and
missing values they are a very very
common problem in big data so those who
have worked with our and you know pandas
data frames you already know there are
functions that could address this
problem so in this section I will
introduce two more functions to deal
with this missing data problem
so there's two functions which is the
drop n a function which will drop the
records that have missing values and the
fill in a function which can be used to
replace missing values with a default
value so there are three ways you can
you know validate the null nerves of a
record one thing is you could assume if
any row any column is now you can assume
I have to either discard this or
whatever and if all the values are now
then that's another criteria and the
other criteria would be you have a
subset of columns that are that you
require to be not now so you have this
subset keyword which can be used to you
know define which columns you need to
you know drop oh you know replace with a
different default value so once you do
this you have all the helpful zeros and
yeah so whenever I don't have an overall
I've just dropped all those reviews
because they are not important to me
let's say and moving from here so we
have the same function as similar to you
know filter filter Indian base basic
Spock are dd's so here what you do is
you have this let's say now I call this
the dense BF because it doesn't have any
missing values so dense d f dot you do
the filter and inside this anybody so my
goal is to filter all the reviews that
have an overall score greater than or
equal to 3 anybody have any guesses on
what should go inside like maybe the
first keyword is it a lambda
Oh a column name hmm okay good it's a
column name so you put the column name
with the data frame name dense DF dot
over roll greater than or equal to 3 and
yeah lacy spark filter DF dog show yes
so now we've got everything that's
greater than or equal to 3 we put one
here yes it works so ok now we filtered
everything now it's time to start
shuffling so in in cluster computing
there's this transformation which
involves this activity called shuffling
we are you have to actually move the
partitions around and you know
restructure the whole data set so one
way I mean in basic are dd's you have
group by key reduced by geeky kind of
functions to do this so similarly in
spark secure you have a group by
function normally it should be you know
it should be associated with a
summarizing function to get tangible
results like for example count sum
average max min kind of thing because
you get a collection of Records when you
group by something and if you want to
you know represent that in one value you
can run something like one of these
summarization functions to do that so
here what I am doing is I am grouping
all these reviews by the overall schoo
it's gone and I am building something
like a frequency histogram so
I have the filter dear from that I group
by overall and I do account to summarize
the result so when I run that yes so I
can see a lot of people are happy so
then let's move to joining data frames
together this is also kind of similar to
you know bass basic rdds so you need to
start a join you need two data sets so
first time let me just run this this is
just you know loading it as a text file
so here I am actually so this is the
product data set so i am defining a new
schema for the product data set and here
you can see there's the map type so if
you look at sales rank sales frank is a
dictionary of string keys and integer
values so that is what i am defining
here i have the sales rank map type with
the string key and integer value so this
works so I have a little question so
imagine like yeah for for the rest of
the tutorial I don't actually need this
related field Oh image URL 0 sales rank
feel what might happen if i remove these
from the schema and try to apply to the
data so there are two options this kima
will fail oh it will work fine who's for
one answer number one yep one
okay who's 42 that it works fine oh you
you want it to work fine no vale fine
cool yes it will work fine so you remove
these three guys and it works just fine
so now I have the product data set and I
have the reviews data set so in this
code snippet I am just doing a simple
join so here what I am doing is I have
the filter DF which is the filtered
version of the reviews I am joining that
with the product data frame that I just
loaded to spark and as the second
parameter I am Telling spark what is the
field that should be used to join these
two data frames and yon in the same step
I am piping a drop in a just to get rid
of anything that doesn't have a title
just for like my own use so when i run
this is so the key difference between
our DD and the data frame here is that
if you want to do the same process with
an RDD and you have this you know row of
tuples so row like a dictionary or
whatever first you have to run it
through a mapper where you get this ace
in field as the key in both the data
frames though the arteries and then do
the joint and then run another mapper to
convert it back to the data format that
you want it to be used so in in data
frames you don't actually have to do
that you just tell what you need to
spark and it does all the you know
required processing under the hood and
it do it in the most optimized way it
could find so you have this enriched we
use now
it's realized and if you have a look at
it you can see that there's the Eason so
this Dec not both the data frames which
is the same and now we have fused the
review data to the product data so yeah
the final bit in the sense final bit
about the data frames then you can save
data frames so i won't go detail into
detail about saving the data frame one
small thing i want to tell is so there
are multiple platforms that you can save
in you can do it to the local dist HDFS
s3 and there are so many other plugins
there are different formats including
park aj's and so on and so forth and
there are like wind spark ships it
already comes with like g-sib l0 and
snappy compressions so it's like you
have so many options depending on your
practical implementation and your
requirements you can decide what how to
save your data so before I dive into
spark secure let me get back to the
slides just to change things of it so
now you guys might like some of you guys
might be thinking okay now we learned
about our dd's now we learnt about data
frames they both do the same thing and
you should ask like why do you even have
to use data frames right so to answer
that I get to this benchmark that data
brakes released about couple of months
ago so this is like they try to agree d
8 10 million integer pairs and this is
the number like in the same cluster
formulation and the results that they
achieved so what we can gather from this
is that both our scholar dd's and python
oddities they have to get hands on with
the programming language like Scala
performs better than Python because it's
closer to JVM and spark is written in
Scala and Python when it wants to
convert everything to scala it has to do
all these conversions do the pie for j
translations and everything so what
happens
in the data frame API is that it's just
an API sitting on top of an optimization
engine so what we actually code is just
an expression of what we need and
instantly what's par this is it converts
it into a different optimized plan and
it carries it out in the same way so
that is the reason why this pi spot
Python data frame and the Scala pipe and
data frames perform the same at the same
time because it doesn't have to it
doesn't have anything beyond its control
like lambda function so on and so forth
it doesn't have to actually worry about
you know giving any sort of control to
the developer in terms of the
optimization it can handle everything
together so just to understand this more
I will briefly go through what happens
when you write a spark sequel query or a
data frame like data frame quarry so you
have this data frame Oh spark sequel
query at first and this unresolved
logical plan is like the bear form of
you know the query that you submit to
spark and from that so spark has this
catalyst optimized stage optimizer which
has a catalog which keeps track of you
know what tables what data frames are
available in my context what data frames
are connected to which tables which
functions are registered to which pipe
and functions so on and so forth so
using that information from the script
that we submit spark builds its own
logical plan and then it takes that
logical plan and it optimizes whatever
the steps that can be optimized that's
something similar to query optimization
and after getting that optimized logical
plan it generates a series of physical
plans out of it and using several cost
models it finds figures out what is the
most efficient physical plan and it
execute the query so just an example
about how the how
Oh like it moves from this logical plan
to of terminological fran a plan we all
have an idea about corey optimization so
if we take an example here my quarry
would be okay I need I need to join
these products and reviews together from
the a scene and I want to filter any
review that was made for products that
are more than 50 bucks in price so the
normal way to do it is like you scan it
scan it you join the two together and
then you filter out the valid lines so
if you think about it you can actually
do the filter on the products before
doing the joint and you will have less
number of lines in the product data set
before the join happens so that will
optimize the join straightaway and spark
when you specially if you use data
frames and intelligent data formats like
[ __ ] it can go further down the pipe and
like for instance if you want to do a
query with certain columns and if you
are using parquet it is sin that
columnar access like the required
columns deep into the reading likes can
face and you can actually do the filters
can while reading the data itself so
this is how these optimizations are
achieved so from here we'll do a bit of
spark secure which would be pretty easy
descry yep
so spark seeker it's very similar to you
know no molecule you use in day-to-day
life so here so because it has the same
functionality as data frames I am NOT
going to you know elaborate step-by-step
on different functions of secure instead
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take about two queries with multiple
functions and show you guys how do you
do it so from that you will get one
thing you will get good understanding
about you know different keywords
popsicle keywords and then you will get
an understanding about how multiple
functions can be used together to make
complex queries so in this first example
so to start with now I was talking about
this thing called the catalog so when
you have a data frame data frame is just
you know it's a data object with a
schema but the sequel context has no
idea about like when you have sequel it
has no idea about what if this is a
table Oh what so for in order for us to
map these different data frames to this
Spock cql space like the world you have
this function score register functions
so you can use this one function code
register as table to make a link between
a data frame and a table reference in
your sexual context and so here what I
am doing is I am reading that Park a
file that I save just did I save it oh
no ok so I'm loading that Sparky file
back and then so what I am doing is I
have this review data frame that I am
loading now and the product data frame
that I noted earlier so I am registering
both these data frames as tables in my
sequel context so I run this and at the
same time I am just this print is just
to check that if the data sources are
loaded
properly so now we can use these reviews
and products table keywords inside the
sequel inside our secular commands and
it will and catalog will know okay
products refers to product DF data frame
so now we have this query where I am
selecting the Germans is in review text
overall price from these different data
frames which are registered as tables
with the join and I am filtering
anything that has a price of more than
fifty dollars so yes so now that is how
you register tables the same time if I
have ten minutes yeah quickly go through
this for like in the next five minutes
so there's another thing you know if you
have used hype before you have
user-defined functions insecure you have
stored procedures so similarly there's a
way in spark signal where you can
introduce functions into the sequel
space using this other function which is
called register function so what i'm
doing here is I have a Python function
which I am registering as two lowercase
in the sacral space and then I can use
it in query where I do the two lowercase
and here we can use s to you know rename
the field because its sequel and you run
this so here i have an example where i
have done a few lines of code where i
have loaded something in a data frame
converted it to a normal r DD done a
mapper they're converted it back to an
RDD back to a data frame and run some
sequel queries on it so the whole
take-home lesson from that bit is that
you can mix and match anything inside
the spark ecosystem to best serve your
requirement and
from that just argue get back to the so
register function it looks really handy
if you want to do some complicated thing
it's I mean it looks like a very useful
tool but the thing is when you do when
you introduce the register function into
the sacral space you have to realize
that there's actual Python code which is
being introduced which the optimizer
doesn't want to touch so at that at that
point the data frame has to convert
things to python and you know do that
communication and all that so the chart
that I showed earlier those performance
guarantees do not really hold when you
do something like register function so
if you are working with the process
heavy function and if you want to use
parks equal to do that you might have to
consider if it is work to do it rather
than can do it in the co r DD form of
the data set and finally yes inferring
was a supplying schema inferring schema
is easy is convenient but then by
default what infernal scheme adresses it
treats the first line of the data set
and alternatively you can tell it to
sample from the data set to a particular
ratio but if you have if you are not
really sure that if that sampling ratio
would not give the full picture above
the data schema structure then that
might become a problem so personally I
prefer to use apply schema berrabah work
with data frames because I know what I
am handling with at the same time spark
knows what it's dealing with so yeah
less room for error developer defines
the schema but yeah just a bit of
development effort so yes so there are
links so there's the data set and so the
data frame there are some useful links
about you know blog posts about data
frames and if you are really interested
in you know learning spark and getting
to know about it I would
really recommend you to one thing go
through all the slides that data breaks
is releasing in the SlideShare profile
and then they have excellent talks in
the YouTube channel about like Tech
Talks internals and this different
application case studies they they come
really handy when you want to really get
hands-on and you know work with them if
you want to get some you know so with
Spock 1.4 they have really worked on the
secure stuff and they have a very good
documentation with some programming
lessons so that might be of help and
yeah questions yep and at the end we are
hiring so yeah if you like spark and if
you like to work with us with like us
please contact us yep and yes you may
fire your questions now
yeah so there's a class layout and he
said that there's a performance like if
you map your so if you apply your own
like yeah phone functions to the data
frame but if you if you use the rdd
sorry did you say again if you map map
it using the RDD then the performance
then it deals with a lot better do the
same but it all depends on let's say if
you want to run like if like if it's one
simple function that's fine but
sometimes you might find you can like
rather than writing a complicated
function which you will register to the
sequel it's rather easier to convert it
to a dataframe run through like a five
step process and get back okay I mean
it's just a very I mean it's more less
like a heuristic than you have to think
and then decide what it would be like
you could do a few benchmarks no cuz i
just remember using a pandas dataframe
and i used my own customer at night AG
function for the aggregate are getting
together on a Greek object and it is so
much longer to do it than the pre
written once I just that's why I want it
was
I thanks all for a tutorial I was
wondering if you're using Amazon s3 what
are the best practices of using Amazon
s3 and with a spark cluster that is
deployed on ec2 so the data is when i
was on a three years so well best
practices hmm yeah i mean you must be
surely using this park in situ script is
it oh I using EMR rose oh there's
storage again is it you should we 12 y
sus dedos you should we move to storage
first or can you just create originator
frames for data iess we directly so what
we do is we pull from s3 directly and we
just why we created our DD saying the
RDD is in a string in this file oh god
yeah also you can just directly works
yes so yeah I mean in text file pocket
file there's s3 and protocol you can
just give the URL and pull straight from
yeah I mean that's what we do yes most
of the innocence mainly like it depends
on if you want to do a batch process we
think about it but if we want to do
molas like etl stuff kind of then we use
something like pocket because then we
only have to pull what we need yes
thank you for the tutorial I just one
question for Spock sequel is it possible
to specify the execution plan because
the optimizes try to do the best but
maybe I mean I've seen it in sick well
sometimes you can do better but in
secret it's very very hard to tell it
how in which order to do the joins the
filtering sorry I didn't get the
question is it possible to specify the
execution plan in the sparks equal
execution plan I wouldn't really do that
because I mean the whole point of data
frames and securely is there is a lot of
work that's going underneath to you know
optimize everything so what do you mean
by an execution because I've says in
sequence of thumbs up Tomas it gives you
a plan it's not always the best yes so I
haven't really i mean dig that deep into
doing that sort of stuff right now like
we are fairly satisfied and yes okay
that's great thank you I thank you for
the tutorial what are the best practice
is to manage utf-8 I'm getting a lot of
issues like converting you'll be very
utf-8 the string so when when i load
data with from json into into a spout
data frame that's working but when I
save it I it breaks any yeah but how do
you deal with that
I when when you read the file you
encoding
all right thank you very much guys have
a good day